unfolding murder case in south carolina
that's taken a startling turn alex
murdah a prominent lawyer in that area
was shot and wounded on labor day
weekend nearly three months after his
wife and son were murdered no one has
been arrested or charged for that double
killing but authorities now say murdoch
hired a gunman to kill him
in an alleged insurance fraud scheme
nikki batiste has the rest of the story
police cars lined this street in hampton
county south carolina earlier this month
it's where prominent local attorney alex
murdoch says he was shot in the head
while changing a flat tire but now law
enforcement says there's more to his
story they announced the arrest
overnight of 61-year-old curtis smith
the charges assisted suicide assault and
battery and insurance fraud among others
police say more charges are expected
charging documents allege murdoch
conspired with smith to shoot him in the
head if murdoch died his living son
would have received an estimated 10
million dollars as part of a life
insurance policy instead murdoch
survived it's the latest twist in the
tragic story of this well-known south
carolina family murdoch's wife maggie
and son paul were both shot and killed
on the family's property in june alex
murdoch made this 9-1-1 call when he
says he found their bodies i've been up
to it now it's bad okay
okay and are they breathing
no ma'am okay and you said it's your
wife and your son
my wife and my son
that crime remains unsolved but alex
murdoch is also the subject of a
separate investigation this month he was
forced out of his law firm for allegedly
misusing company money he released a
statement to apologize and also revealed
he'd enter rehab for an apparent opioid
addiction alex murdock is not charged in
his shooting and has not responded to
requests for comment about that or the
fraud allegations for cbs mornings i'm
nikki batiste in hilton head south
carolina
no i've been watching this story for the
last couple weeks it's been bizarre from
the very beginning yeah that he is shot
in the head and then you find out it's
grazed and that he survives and he calls
9-1-1 it's just that there's still been
no arrests for the death of the mother
and the son and now he's resigned from
his law firm it's very very and the the
guy who was arrested curtis edward smith
is a client of his yeah not only is he a
bad shot but he's a relationship yes
they have a relationship and we keep
saying prominent lawyer what we mean by
prominent is his great-grandfather
grandfather and father were the top
prosecutor in that area for almost a
hundred years yeah it's a big story in
south carolina from grace